so 2018 didn't really have the big
Nintendo game well not yet but the big
Nintendo games like breath of the wild
Super Mario Odyssey stuff like that
Smash Brothers is on the way we got a
new Pokemon but not quite a big Pokemon
what was this year really defined by
what Nintendo did necessarily with the
switch or what other people did with
switch because I think if anything
there's a really good sophomore year for
other developers gonna get in do their
stuff yes the switch continues to be my
favorite place to play games and a lot
of that is because games that either
missed or I didn't have a chance to play
for whatever reason I've been ported to
switch like hollow Knight it's a good
example we have Diablo 3 was a great
port we had a lot of really good ports
especially Bethesda jumping on the
switch trains Bethesda was very anti
porting to Nintendo and we've gotten
Wolfenstein switch which like was really
good docked you know there's still a
little wiggle room and like an
adjustment period there right but I do
think it was very positive to see a lot
of developers jumping on switch and
seeing the potential of the console
neither word the second year end is that
like kind of the cracks are showing with
some of those ports like the fezzes
games for example sip 6 which I've been
playing right you saying the controls
are kind of weird it's it's not that the
controls are bad it's just it shows the
limitations of what you can do on the
switch right not there aren't many
limitations but like I think it's
telling that sip 6 and darkest dungeon
are the two games I would say I would
not prefer on switch everything else you
mentioned Halle Knight dead cells I
played on switch like endlessly that's
what people derided the switch for this
year they're saying oh it's just a port
machine I was like that's why I loved it
because that only matters if you're
trying to compete like put one right
right platform against another and like
Frank from a like looking at Nintendo I
think that was a really good strategy I
think like padding the the time between
the Pokemon and smash and like anything
else that came early this year as far as
exclusives I think that was a good way
to do it like reintroduce hollow nights
of people bring like salt and sanctuary
to switch bringing all these games to
switch that people might have played and
want to just replay or like just
reintroducing people to them in general
wedding people's appetite for Pokemon
right yeah I mean Pokemon was actually a
big highlight for me this year and I was
I was very hesitant about it I don't
want to say I was expecting to dislike
it but I was pleasantly surprised by the
game because I you know I'm
pretty hardcore about Pokemon uh-huh and
I was really looking forward to the new
Pokemon put once which being like the
the new one that people just refer to it
as that coming out in 2019 let's go I
was kind of like okay this is like
Pokemon for babies that doesn't mean
it's bad like I'm happy to play a
relaxing Pokemon game but I found a lot
more deaths there than I was expecting
and it actually got me really a lot more
excited for the real one right but I
wouldn't even call it the real one it's
just the next ones this one has enough
for me to dive into because like
catching pokémon and let's go is so so
good it's the most I've wanted to catch
pokemon in a really long time normally
I'm just kind of like catch one get in
my pokedex I'm done right so I think
like what they changed about it when
they introduced the Pokemon go mechanics
I think a lot of people were hesitant
about but I think turned out really well
for it
[Music]
I think one of the most exciting things
though is being able to play pokemon on
a console on a big screen like I I still
think the best way to play is handheld
but seeing that worlds on a big TV with
these bright vibrant colors as opposed
to playing on a small handheld I think
is exciting and I think Pokemon 2019 is
gonna be very exciting because hopefully
they'll kind of push that even further I
don't know make it more involved in that
world it's nice to see you like that
proof of concept of what Pokemon could
look like and seeing like the 3d models
in the overworld
I think Game Freak gets a lot of heat
before the games come out when they
change things so like the Pokemon go
catching mechanics in this one black and
white doesn't have any of the previous
Pokemon like you started that game and
it was just like the new Pokemon but
black and white ended up being a lot of
people's favorite generation for that so
when they take risks I think it actually
turns out really well for the Pokemon
series so I'm excited just seeing this
with minimal risk take in what they
could do with the next one you had a
proof of concept I think of the entire
one in Tendo is in 1000 online
yeah which was like kind of we were all
really wondering what that was gonna be
like and then it launched and now it's
here and like what do we know right I
was gonna say like it's funny that a
port Diablo 3 was the game that got me
to finally like again that's that's a
positive thing for the ports and
Nintendo is like a six year old game
that fun kinda like got me to finally
buy a Nintendo online but still I get so
frustrated with like Nintendo is kind of
lagging behind things that we take for
granted on other console more than PC
and everything and like I still wish
Nintendo like in some area to just get
its head out of the sand and catch up
which I guess it has now but sort of
yeah like not entirely I think they're
the value they're offering for 20 bucks
is pretty good
but like what's the most you really get
out of that the ability to play games
online and Nintendo games like NES games
yeah you guys know I love retro games
right but NES games are the most basic
form of retro game that gets recycled
over and over and over again especially
by a Nintendo like I would've loved to
have seen some online multiplayer for
Super Nintendo games for example
something more exciting then here's
Excitebike again here's Mario Brothers
again we own another Nintendo console
yeah yeah
we've all played them a hundred times
before like I don't know I would just
love to see other games get a second
lease on life if Nintendo is gonna use
those to prop up the subscription
service because that would be the one
thing that gets me going
yeah it doesn't to be honest I
completely forgot about that the whole
Nintendo Ellen until I was playing
Pokemon we're trying to trade and it was
like no we can't do this until you get
in 1000 and I was like haha [ __ ] okay
and then now I have it but I completely
forgotten so far it's like I mean it
wasn't that much money like but still
it's like I yeah I don't see it yet that
I paid for this when I was already using
it for a year and a half well that's the
other thing too is they took it a
multi-player away from splatoon too
right yeah they suddenly turned this key
and they're like all right sorry you
know you've got to pay for that that's
really strange I kind of very surprised
that they did that it seems a very
inelegant of them yeah yeah you'd think
like for future games maybe they would
implement it from the start but for one
that you've been playing for free online
yeah it's a little strange I think they
said it from the beginning when the game
launched even nobody transparent about
it yeah but it's still weird can we
finally give a eulogy 3ds no you you
think so yeah what came out this year
I love the 3ds 3ds detective Pikachu why
are you we're going oh yo Kai watch
blasters and then next year beginning
next year yokai watch 3 or whatever yeah
there's still no love yokai watchee just
not in this country so much yeah and I
do love the 3ds it's just it's funny
because I was thinking about when I'm
like some of my favorite experiences on
3ds were like they're like several co-op
experiences that kind of highlighted why
I love the switch and it is more
frustrating that the switch took so long
to get on board with online because
being in the same room with like three
other people playing Diablo on their own
switches was so fun and satisfying and
being able to just link up seamlessly it
reminded me of like playing Triforce
heroes a game I don't like but I played
it on 3ds and that worked out really
well
yeah it's no labo though yes this year's
been really long and I forgot the labo
came out this year yeah no just lob oh
yeah I never touched labo and Nintendo's
follow up to it like it's second wave of
stuff was kind of
it almost matter right like I heard it
was actually improving and not that I
was bad to begin with la Bo's
interesting because I don't think a lot
of us in this office are in the audience
for it at all but I found it to be just
something different
utilizing this much hardware in an
interesting way that is a good
jumping-off point for a lot of things I
think the best thing about it was toi
con garage which is like the programming
where you can program your own so when
you're building the toy cons that come
in the kit that's very like it's just
like building Legos the directions are
really clear and easy and fun I think
it's I don't know if I would have been
able to do it when it was really young
but it's something that like a kid can
do pretty easily but then once you get
those foundations it does a great job of
teaching you how to make your own or
make modifications to them and I think
that's really interesting like I would
have loved to have that as a kid just as
a trying out programming sort of thing
and it's not like hardcore programming
at all but the concepts are really
called present they're the if bends you
know if this but not this kind of but I
like I don't know Randy played with his
eight-year-olds and the piano was super
cool and like that's something that
really captures kids imagining yeah well
entertainment now is all about screens
yeah and so yeah screens are still a
part of this thing but it's so much more
than that it brings the experience into
the real world and gives you more agency
over a game than you would normally
because you're actually making the fact
it would be cool like if you I mean I
grew up building Legos like if I could
have done something with them once I
built them that would have been really
cool and this is a similar concept that
I think just gotten overlooked by a lot
of people because it's the games the
actual what is technically what we refer
to as a game are not impressive they're
they're just detected
you gave me a bit of a segue and I'm
gonna take it talk about they overlooked
right like the switch is a device that
can be used in landscape or portrait
mode and some games are made for that
but antenna doesn't like give you a way
to actually put the joy cones on the
side this thing the flip grip is coming
out really soon and I it's like for a
very specific type of person it's for
arcade ports on the switch
it sounds really dumb but it got me
thinking now that I'm using it it's like
why the hell isn't intend to embracing
this why aren't there being games
developed as like staring at the camera
seminarian
it's true I am but so are you guys here
we go down well it would be cool now
what would be great on that like I feel
like there's a whole dimension to the
switch there really isn't being tapped
into at large by Nintendo I don't know
I'm pretty stoked by the flip grip but I
guess I don't mean to make it sound like
an afterthought but for all of its flaws
octa path traveller was one of my
favorite games this year it was it's I'm
not traditionally into JRPGs but and I
know I would realize that game has flaws
and it's writing and it's it becomes
repetitive but I absolutely love just
having eight characters and the overall
vibe of that game and like I think it to
its detriment it stayed pretty
old-school in a lot of ways and became
archaic in some fashion but and more
like what respects I thought like they
just really leaned into the repetition
once you see the formula for like how
you're traveling through the world in a
spiral and kind of doing each character
you can do like one character see them
all the way through to the end but then
once I started to see the pattern it
didn't really deviate from that as much
as I would have liked to and the writing
sometimes flat-out bad yeah Tresa
specifically people said Trece as their
favorite story in that a lot of people
said that I don't know okay like a
go-getter she's gonna do
bring it on
[Music]
coming it's out dance
[Applause]
yeah I really like that gave us gorgeous
and for me think the combat was
compelling enough to overlook some of
those story flaws like I didn't need the
story to carry me through that gameplay
if that makes sense sometimes they work
in tandem the story and gameplay are
both interesting enough and you they
kind of just carry you through it
I found the combat really really
engaging and I liked it a lot and I
didn't need so much of the story stuff
to get me going at the beginning I was
just like right there with it
especially especially the boss fights I
know the boss fight that game were so
good
there's so many bubbles in the air while
you're fighting yeah it was pretty
demanding like I feel like if I like
accidentally did the wrong move I would
have like okay I screwed over this run
like I got a neck up in a 20-minute
fight if I slide so sometimes they're
frustrating but when you did it it was
super satisfying and also just the
sprites in general or the the when
they're all huge yeah yeah they look
really cool on screen there's a lot like
Final Fantasy sixes bosses where it
would take those cute little super
dimension guys and make him his big bro
- yeah whatever that game was good
before it came out I think that was like
oh this is one of the biggest things on
switch this year and I guess it
technically was far as exclusives go but
once it came out I feel like it kind of
slowly died away for maybe good reason
because it wasn't as good as people had
hoped but I really like that game Mario
aces Mario Tennis aces I thought was
pretty good too yeah shallow though it
was super shallow there Joey Motors is
really quick but there was a lot more
depth to a tennis game that I thought
that tennis isn't deep but considering
the previous mario tennis games dare you
insult
[Music]
a lot of people compared it to fighting
games in that yes the characters you've
picked head were very important in terms
of like size weight and then and it came
down to more about breaking their net
meter radio did you have to juggle a lot
of different meters and determine how
hard you're gonna shoot or whether
you're gonna block a shot it was a
decent game just a decent game but it's
just yeah it was one of those where it
was like crap
Nintendo could have done like an amazing
job of yeah I play spend more time with
it maybe yeah I played like four or five
hours and I enjoyed it but I have not
desire to go back all right Super Mario
Party Party it's not a system seller but
it was kind of like I had fun with it it
was fun like on Thanksgiving I played
for a few hours and it kind of showcase
some of the novelties of like the HD
Rumble and the the joy cons on their own
I'm not gonna do the motions I know but
decent game does fun I feel like the
switch could have had an off year but I
mean smash is like yeah basically here
yeah
my game is gonna be big I mean obviously
it will be it's the most premium
Nintendo game ever yeah yeah but coming
on the tail end of the year I think it
could have made Nintendo feel like ahead
a bit of an off year although like I
don't know like in terms of exclusives
and everything but the fact that so many
of games that I've played in games I
wanted to play and just never had an
excuse to go to the fact that they came
out on switch and we're like better on
switch than anywhere else is just you
could call it padding to be reductive
but it wasn't I think like they really
like bolstered the switches value I
don't know if we talked about that sells
to like even though they came to all
platforms pretty much I think I spent 50
hours playing dead cells on switch and
that is one of my favorite games of the
year yeah
yeah I think like the lack of
big exclusives compared to last year is
not as big a deal when you think of like
even if these things aren't exclusive I
played a lot of these games on switch
because it was the switch mm-hmm and so
that to me says it wouldn't have been an
off year for a Nintendo either they
didn't have smash because if you're
consistently picking up your switch and
using it
that's me using my switch you know
buying games don't even have time to
play on switch because it's like I want
this on switch
I bought holo tonight cuz it was on sale
and I like still haven't really gotten
into it I was just like I need this in
my library to have it when I'm on a
plane yeah it's still it's still like a
special console handheld whatever you
want to call it yeah anything I'm
looking forward to what they do with the
hardware next they're gonna get er eight
that on there which they will well
they've been like yeah they've they've
all but said that they are gonna be kind
of pursuing what Sony Microsoft have
done with their improved switch or
whatever they're gonna make it I don't
know what they're gonna do with that
alright so those are our thoughts on the
switch from 2018 but we've got more
organized formal thoughts on the page to
celebrate the end of the year and lots
of best of the year coverage coming
along as well so stay tuned and
gamespot.com
[Music]